Timmermans heeft een opinie stuk
geschreven in vrij Nederland.
En men is verontwaardigd.
Zo neemt Timmermans
bijvoorbeeld letterlijk het pers bericht over van CIDI
in zijn stuk.
En zoals we weten is CIDI de lobby organisatie van Israel.
Maar verbaast het jullie?
Tijdens de verkiezingstijd heeft Timmermans
toch genoeg ‘red flags’
laten zien?
Dat heeft destijds jullie ogen helemaal niet geopend.
Daarentegen jullie hebben je nagels
rood geverfd om met hem te kunnen matchen.
Dat heeft consequenties gehad
want van de kiezers voor groenlinks PvdA
kwam 2% van bij1 en 3% kwam van PvdD.
Dit betekent dat van de 1.643.073 stemmen
32.861 extra stemmen had kunnen betekenen voor bij1.
en 49.202 90 stemmen voor PvdD.
Dit zou betekenen dat bij1 de zetel had behouden
en dat de PvdD niet 3
maar 4 zetels had gehad in de Tweede Kamer.
En nee dit had niet Palestina bevrijd
I know maar dan was er tenminste
een sterkere oppositie
geweest voor het zionistisch gezwets
in de Tweede Kamer.
Achteraf verontwaardiging is niet voldoende
jullie stemgedrag heeft consequenties gehad.